a series of car bomb explosions within
hours of each other
Chu and the capital Quito targeting
officers of the prison's Authority two
other bombs detonated in a province
bordering Peru
there was a new explosion of a truck
type vehicle that had two gas cylinders
inside that have exploded due to the
action of explosive devices especially
this dynamite type Emulsion causing the
destruction of the truck and damage to
the exterior of the building of the
national service for persons deprived of
Liberty and Adolescent offenders
injuries have been
reported Fernando Villa vicencio
he was gunned down after an election
rally in Quito
as before the Bomb Blast in the capital
in middlet Correction Facility in the
city of Cuenca took 50 guards and seven
police officers hostage
ministers say the car bombings and
hostage situation when response to the
relocation of some prisoners and
attempts to clean up prisons which are
controlled by rival gangs the increase
in prison violence is worrying the
government
we're obviously concerned about the
safety of our officials both police and
prison guards we're already expecting
action which will be communicated to you
but we are in that line of action
gang members imprisoned in Ecuador often
fight each other because of their links
to Colombian and Mexican drug cartels
the turf wars in jail have killed at
least 430 inmates in the past two years
in July the outgoing president guermo
lasso announced a 60-day state of
emergency in prisons to allow the Army
to be sent in
illegal drug gangs are also fighting
turf wars on the streets with murder
rates higher than in Brazil Colombia and
Mexico
stemming violence both inside and
outside prisons is a main demand for
many ecuadorians who will vote in the
presidential runoff election next month
Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera